so underneath your heading what I'd love
you to jot down is a table just like the
client that you were making in 1201
which is just one of the many ways that
we can use to describe a pattern and
then bring a rule out of that so what
I'm gonna do is I'm going to show you a
quick example of what I'm talking about
and then you're going to have a go at
this yourself that's why we have so many
matchsticks today they're not mainly for
me they're mainly for you so let's have
a look at this now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to create a pattern here
and what I'd love you to do is two
things for this first example and we're
gonna draw the pattern as it grows and
then we're going to create a table that
corresponds to that now we're just going
to work this first example together so
that when I give you a few that I'm not
going to work through with you you'll
know what to do okay so let's start off
real real simple we're going to begin
let me see that yes fantastic I'm gonna
begin with I'll move over a little bit
so you can see it there so we've got
these mastics actually I need to be a
little further over this way it looks
like okay so yeah that'll do I think
that'll be enough space so you can see
this is my first shape so this is going
to be shape one so I'm gonna go to my
table I'm gonna say shape one and you
can tell me how many matchsticks
it requires it's just four fantastic so
this is a relationship between the
number of shapes the number of matrix
and I'm just going to make this pattern
grow now I'm gonna do a really simple
one for this first one so the next one
I'm gonna put on and see if I put this
in the right spot and I'm gonna move it
up a little bit actually up is down on
my screen so yeah sorry you're just a
bit too high there we go okay here comes
the next one
could you please draw this as a separate
shape so you'll need to draw a whole
first copy of this one and then your
second shape will include both of them
together so shape number one you can
draw it up you've already done it
probably and then shape number two is
both of them put together so I love them
to be separate so this is shape number
two and again you can count how many
matchsticks it requires altogether I've
got eight fantastic okay one last one
bless you to establish the pattern and
then we can go from there here we go
okay so this is a final one I'm going to
show you in the pattern if I can get it
in the right spot how's that can you see
the whole thing okay fantastic so this
is shape number three
and how many matchsticks have I got in
total 12 excellent okay now from here we
could do one of two things we could
either work out what you think the next
shape will be without actually drawing
it or we could also create a
relationship a pattern a rule that
explains what's going on here okay so
maybe we'll do it in order how many
without actually constructing yet how
many matchsticks will I need if I add on
shape number four vishakha seem to be
that up sixteen now how do we get
sixteen without actually doing it Louise
what are you seen yes
[Music]
aha you're talking about one here right
now I guess this is a bit tricky when
you're trying to establish a pattern
right I could have all different kinds
of patterns for all for all you know I
could be going up and around or I could
be going and creating just more squares
and I could put in two here and I'd get
another square but I am trying to make
this up and down and up and down so I'm
going to continue going in this
direction even though I could validly
have given that answer as well so here's
my question right what's the
relationship between s the number of
shades are up to and and the number of
matchsticks that we used go ahead here s
times for s times 4 equals M do you
agree with that whatever shape number
you've got you just multiply it by 4 and
off you go okay fantastic well I know
what you do just underneath this is to
write down that this is what we call a
simple linear pattern we'll explain what
we mean by that middle web which is kind
of really important and unusual a little
bit later on but for now just like you
to have it jot it down okay now for this
next one I'm not gonna ask you to write
it down I just want to give you a sense
of what something that isn't quite so
simple looks like so don't worry about
writing or drawing this next part in
fact just put the pencils out of your
hands and pens out your hands and just
watch for this next bit okay so this
next pattern is gonna start the same way
whoops I'm a bit on Quinn it okay it
begins in exactly the same way that we
saw before but I'm gonna build it in a
very very slightly different fashion
okay so this time without drawing it or
writing it I just want you to think
about the difference between this
pattern and the previous one here's
shape number two so we started off the
same way shape number two though I'm
building it a little bit differently I
want you to think about this for a
second okay
and then where do you think shape no
three is going to go off to the right so
I'm going to put down let's use this one
this one
and this one oops okay so this one's a
little more unusual isn't it I still end
up with three squares don't I but I'm
building it in a bit of a different
fashion okay we're gonna hit pause I
asked you not to do the writing the
drawing just now but now that I've shown
you the whole thing I'd like you to go
through again create a table it doesn't
have to be big or beautiful but we want
the numbers in there you can see the
completed shape now and you can sort of
rewind back in time to see what shape -
and shape one word and then again I want
you to see if you can come up with a
rule for this have a think call me over
if you reckon you have something just
think it'd be shut down first and I
won't give everyone a bit more time
Jessica what would be a really good
question is how could you convince
yourself in that case with that say this
is these are I saying
yes that's correct or no that's wrong
like what maybe what what makes you
think that
how could you convince a friend for
example that's what we think the rule is
okay Harriet it's in
interesting so what I want to ask you is
how can you tell whether this is correct
or not but count the squares and tell me
the matchsticks mm-hmm is pretty much
the pattern that I got mm-hmm
so one of the great ways we can know
whether a baton is right or not is to
see what happens for the next one to
continue okay
okay I'm seeing a few more hands up it's
okay if not everyone is there I wonder
if someone can suggest to me what
they've got for their pattern between s
and M have you got a new equation for
you Merrick what are you thinking 1
times 3 plus 1 okay so let's just hold
on for a second right what we've got
here yes s times 3 yeah okay before we
go on to that what have we got here well
this is a an explanation of the rule but
in a specific example this would be
which check number this is this is the
first one isn't it because one times
three plus one that's four matchsticks
which is the way the shape began yes but
what we want to do is say what about for
any particular shape what for - for
three for four so we put our s in here
what would be a way we usually actually
don't write s times 4 or s times 3 we
have a shorter lazy way of doing it
we usually say for s here or 3s here
that make sense ok and maybe you already
wrote that down straight away now what
I'd love you to do is to label this one
as well it's not just a simple linear
pattern we had to modify it a little bit
you see we didn't just use
multiplication I had to include this
other operation I had to do some
addition as well and you could do
subtraction too depending on the pattern
you create all right now I've shown you
two patterns I'm gonna show you one last
one and this time we're not gonna write
anything down at all I'm just going to
show it to you okay so I'm gonna start
off as promised like this we all start
off like this but now the next one I'm
going to put on is going to look a
little different
okay this shape number two can you see
the whole thing sorry that this parts a
bit low you can probably see I'm already
running out of space I'm not going to be
able to draw on or put on the
matchsticks for shape number three so
I'm going to draw it for you
this is shape to well once you predict
shape three looks like how could we add
the lines onto your Dave what are you
thinking I am gonna make another square
but you notice how I went from the first
one I made a bigger square so I'm gonna
make the next one even even bigger it's
gonna keep on going so like this
that's shape number three okay now this
one is even trickier I'm just gonna say
to you guys right now you know how this
was a simple linear pattern this one
I'll label label for you I call this one
am a modified linear pattern this third
one that we just made is not linear at
all it's still a pattern
I mean you could probably give me the
next one right what would the next one
look like yeah I just keep on going
further out and then go like so all
right yeah Jessica a question or do you
have a thought alright yeah
for that one okay interesting
I'm gonna have a conversation with you
in a second for now I want to show you
all where you're going to go from here
wake up computer due to new your thumbs
success okay let's put this down in fact
we might just get the lights for a
second so I could sit real clearly okay
so what we did was we walked you through
those few here I'm not going to walk you
through these because we're going to do
something slightly different for it I've
got three new patterns here that kind of
correspond to the three patterns you
just saw okay this is the final the
third step for each of them so we start
with one then two then three this one we
start with one this kind of L shape up
in the corner and then two and then
three and then how would you describe
what words would you use to describe
that last shape over there it's kind of
like a pyramid right and it's starting
from the top and it's going further and
further down and it's getting bigger and
bigger and bigger at the base okay so
here is what we're going to work on
together and for Part C I don't ask you
to actually work in pairs because I do
not have enough even though it's a lot
of matchsticks it's not enough for every
single individual we're going to have a
disaster on the tables so here's what
I'd like you to do for these three for
these three what I'd love you do is
create the table just like we did before
but do it up to the sixth shape I'm only
showing you up to the third I love you
do do one two three four five and six
for the first two just like we did just
now I'd love you to come up with that
that rule that relates the number of
shapes to then our our matchsticks that
you use and then lastly I'd love you to
come up with your own shapes and there's
going to be one for this one a simple
one one for this one a modified one and
then one that you can't easily come up
with a rule for but you can still draw
okay all right
quick question don't ya they don't have
to touch but we do have to you have to
be able to give this pattern to someone
else and they have to be able to follow
what's going on on the basis of just
looking at it okay so I'm going to leave
this here mrs. Lee's
so we're gonna be giving you these so
you can actually create them but just
like we did for the first one we want
you to be drawing them so that you have
a record of them because after that
these will be gone and you don't get to
keep them sorry we're taking them back
for the next time we teach does that
make sense so you're going to be drawing
and creating some tables and then also
making up your own shapes
any questions